Dear fellow scholars. This is two minute papers with carriage on I,
if I hear finally, the full research paper has appeared on open AI five,
which is an AI that plays Dora to a multiplayer online battle arena game
with a huge cult following. And you may not expect this.
It is not only as good as some of the best players in the world,
but it also describes the surgery technique. That sounds quite unexpected.
And I promise to tell you what it is later during this video,
this game is a nightmare for any AI to play because of three main reasons.
One, it requires long-term strategy planning,
where it is possible that we make one bad decision.
Then a thousand good ones, and we still lose the game in the end,
finding out which decision led to this loss is immensely difficult. Often,
even for humans too, we have imperfect information,
meaning that we can only see what our units and buildings can see. And three,
even though these learning agents don't look at the pixels of the game,
but they see the world as a big bunch of numbers.
There's just too much information to look at and too many decisions to make
compared to chess or go, or almost anything else.
Despite these difficulties in 2017 open AI showed us an initial version
of their agent that was able to play one versus one games with only one
hero and was able to reliably be dandy a world champion player
that was quite an achievement. However, of course,
this was meant to be a stepping stone towards something much bigger.
That is playing the real Dota two. And just two years later,
the newer version named open AI five has appeared,
defeated the Dora to where our champions and beat
99.4% of human players during an online event that ran for
multiple days. Many voices said that this would never happen.
So two years to pull this off after the first version,
I think was an absolute miracle. Bravo.
Now note that even this version has two key limitations,
one in a normal game,
we can choose from a pool of 117 heroes where the system supports
17 of them.
And two items that allow the player to control multiple characters at once
have been disabled.
If I remember correctly from a previous post of theirs in visibility effects are
also neglected because the algorithm is not looking at pixels.
It would either always have this information shown as a bunch of numbers or
never, neither of these would be good design decisions.
So thus invisibility is not part of this technique. Fortunately,
the paper is now available.
So I was really excited to look under the hood for some more details.
So first as I promised, what is this surgery think about?
You see the training of the neural network.
Part of this algorithm took no less than 10 months. Now,
just imagine for,
to feed an important piece of information into the system or finding a bug
where training is underway in cases like this,
normally we would have to aboard the training and start again.
If we have a new idea as to how to improve the system, again,
we have to abort the training and start again.
If an old version of Dora two comes out with some changes, you got stride.
We start again.
This would be okay if the training took from the order of minutes to hours,
but we are talking 10 months here. This is clearly not practical.
So what if there would be a technique that would be able to apply all of these
changes to a training process that is already underway? Well,
this is what the surgery technique is about here with the blue curve.
You see the agents curating improving over time and the red lines with the black
triangles show us the dates for the surgeries.
The author is not that over the 10 month training process,
they have performed approximately one surgery per two weeks.
It seems that getting a doctorate in machine learning research is getting a
whole new meaning.
Some of them indeed made an immediate difference while others seemingly
not so much. So how do we assess how potent these surgeries were?
Did they give the agent superpowers? Well,
have a look at the rerun part here,
which is the final Frankenstein's monster agent containing the result of all the
surgeries retrained from scratch,
and just look at how quickly it is trained. And not only that,
but it shoots even higher than the original agent. Absolute madness.
Apparently open AI is employing some proper surgeons over there at their lab.
I love it. Interestingly,
this is not the only time I've seen the word surgery used in the computer
sciences outside of medicine,
a legendary mathematician named Gregory Pearlman who proved the point.
Curry conjecture also performed a mathematical technique that he called surgery.
What's more,
we even talked about simulating weightlifting and how a simulated AI agent will
walk after getting hamstrung and you guys,
they tried undergoing surgery to fix it. What a time to be alive.
And again,
an important lesson is that in this project open AI is not spending so much
money and resources just to play video games.
Dota two is a wonderful test bed to see how their AI compares to humans
as complex tasks that involve strategy and teamwork. However,
the ultimate goal is to reuse parts of the system for other complex problems
outside of video games. For instance,
the algorithm that you've seen here today can also do this.
This episode has been supported by Linode Linode is the world's largest
independent cloud computing provider. Unlike entry-level hosting services,
Linos gives you full backend access to your server,
which is your step up to powerful, fast, fully configurable cloud computing.
Linode also has one click apps that streamline your ability to deploy websites,
personal VPNs, game servers, and more,
if you need something as small as a personal online portfolio,
Lenovo has your back.
And if you need to manage tons of clients' websites and reliably serve them to
millions of visitors, Lino can do that too. What's more,
they offer affordable GPU instances featuring the Quadro RTX
6,000,
which is tailor made for AI scientific computing and computer graphics projects.
If only I had access to a tool like this while I was working on my PhD studies,
the received $20 credit in your newly node account, visit
lino.com/papers,
or just click the link in the video description and give it a try today.
Our thanks to Linode for supporting the series and helping us make better videos
for you. Thanks for watching and for your generous support.
And I'll see you next time.